[Music]  Digital taxation is an important issue  and that is the reason I invited my  fellow ministers discussed the way we  can be best prepared for the debate at  international level I think we need to  work together on the assessment of the  impact of the various options considered  in osed today we did the listed Aruba  Barbados and Bermuda from our list of  non-cooperative jurisdictions for tax  purposes as a result 12 editions remain  on the you list in for a desk advantage  Finance Minister isn't Fukuoka abandoned  I need a sphere so I not give is int  boom the velvet soft after a loop a  shaft commonly and a creases playin a  policing hub nightly hunters tricks  physican sayin on the second quantity  column went on yet in there forints  leading the north appeal and conn-young  - ah the no trending performance and to  gain unsigned int boom they're over  patient phone source often give up my  design  you